[Musique]
merci jimmy bonjour à vous et à tous nos
auditeurs
bonjour le cru corps bonjour nous sommes
particulièrement honorés d'accueillir
dans ce studio 1 7e dan et quand on
regarde la une d'un article tout récent
puisque vous avez reçu votre distinction
votre grade
officiellement le 20 janvier dernier au
siège fédéral du judo à paris du judo
français et on voit le cru corps au
sommet de la hiérarchie
et c'est vrai que 1 7e dan ne sais pas
c'est très rare dans nos zones ça vient
ça vient récompenser validé combien
d'années de pratique et puis il y à l'un
de vos formateurs qui doit être très
fiers de vous là où son esprit se trouve
en ce moment on pense évidemment à
francisco fois c'est ce que mon
professeur c'est lui qui m'a appris les
pommiers pour mieux lui qui m'a fait
faire les premiers pas dans la
discipline
ça correspond à j'ai commencé en 1966
avec lui donc je suis officiellement
donné 67 et depuis je n'ai pas arrêté
sauf peut-être podor tapas et moi à
mener sans 65 ans vous préparer le
baccalauréat
plusieurs dizaines d'années pour arriver
donc ans en 2018 trentaine d'années
s'est quand même des 52 ans de pratique
où elle a exactement
vous avez fait le compte alors vous
étiez donc à paris au siège fédéral du
judo français pour recevoir avec six
autres récipiendaires
ce 7e dan alors j'ai vu que le grade 7e
dan et dégradent suivants sont pas
attribuées sur la base de présentation
de candidature ou d'examens mais c'est
une sorte de promotion qui s'effectue
après un traitement par la commission
spécialisée des damnés et grade
équivalent de la fédération française de
judo fait c'est ça donc il faut en tout
cas au moins avoir été dix ans 6e dan
oui c'est ça moi et j'ai dû y rester 14
en fait d'éviter pour mieux en 2016 mais
par rapport justement à l'épreuve
j'avais un mémoire présenté technique
l'évolution du judo une réflexion si
c'est le judo qui n'apportent pourquoi à
part au judo français au mondial
donc la paix choisi décrit aussi où
l'arrivée de judo aux antilles guyane à
3 min ça c'est pour le 6e on le sait sa
7e dan j'ai dû donc différée ma
promotion de 2016 et 2017 demandeur
euros pour la fédération le temps de
préparer ce mémoire avec avec six
accords alors il n'y a pas d'examen mais
il a quand même un mémoire présenté il
ya quand même un travail de recherche
près ce qu'on peut dire oui on dit avoir
promis d'un 2e dan jusqu'au 5e dan on
apprend on
on étudie on approfondit m'a pas vu des
6e dan rugby en restitue ce tout ce
qu'on a appris aux autres donc on est là
comme démissionner il faut faire passer
le témoin il faut faire et il faut faire
vivre les vrais messages le fond du judo
il faut donner du temps de l'expérience
pour ça on vous observe
votre circuit donc vous avez participé à
la formation de manière générale et
continue de la fédération française
taulier vous national régional
communauté nationale et mondiale et vous
avez des responsabilités à différents
niveaux
pas tant que dirigeant aussi un truc
quatre techniques ce que c'était mon cas
et puis on suit votre dossier est soumis
à une commission qui étudie votre
situation votre circuit et vous demande
aussi une réflexion nous signifier autre
capable d'arriver un apport de judo
notre histoire
j'ai travaillé ou l'histoire du judo
olemps unique alors c'est assez
exceptionnel à un anti hier on va dire
un antillais en antillo-guyanais à ce
niveau-là du judo alors je vous êtes le
seul actuellement à être 7e dan dans
l'eau et est ce que vous êtes le premier
alors j'ai ouvert la porte c'est
tellement à mes compatriotes
d'autres suivront ensuite j'espère et
oui mais en tant que marque nickel je
suis le troisième acte unique fait
d'accord il ya un paumé marc gicquel
s'est ainsi versé ma fille qui est qui
dans l'émigration les paquets 1961 et
qui a vécu en france qui vit toujours en
france et puis un deuxième ses genoux
elle qui n'est pas revenue martinique
mais les vestes en guyane il a été
conseiller technique aussi sur la
martinique la guadeloupe la guerre et
qui s'est basé sur la guyane
et moi même qui suis ici nicolas mas
péter wyss et ça et donc vous êtes vous
êtes vous a cité deux autres mais qui ne
pratiquent pas qu'ils n'enseignent pas
leur leur art martial en martinique vous
êtes le seul dans ce cas là à être je
dirais presque enfin basé quoi c'est ça
la fait vous n'avez jamais à que leur
revenait au pays a juste peur que 72 et
pour continuer à progresser à paris et
le six vont venir en 1981 et depuis
parce que c'est une décision que j'avais
prise je veux plus rester aussi à paris
pour continuer gravi les échelons mais
je pense que la martinique la ligue de
judo avait besoin de moi des questions
et apporter mon savoir et connaissance à
mes compatriotes et fait monter le
niveau participé à l'organisation du jeu
à l'aseptisation à son développement
nous sommes dans sa roue cathy sur la
première avec le cru corps qui vient
donc d'obtenir un 7e dan de judo
alors vous avez dit justement que vous
êtes en quelque sorte c'est vous êtes un
missionnaire confirmé avec ce grade avec
ce 7e dan et l'enseignement la formation
auprès des plus jeunes c'est aussi et
surtout même votre credo un même encore
en 2018 après plus un peu plus de 50 ans
de pratique une jeunesse en martinique
alors comment bien d'autres lieux du
monde
pour laquelle la pratique justement d'un
art martial de manière générale mais là
en l'occurrence de judo peut-être
salutaire en ces temps troublés
oui parce que le judo un message fort
c'est pas seul une discipline sportive
c'est une discipline d'éducation
fondamentalement il a été cueilli et
pour cela pour former des hommes et des
femmes est saoul il accompagner leur
développement physique mentale sociale
et civique aussi donc d'une mission qui
large le besoin pour me dans la borne
cela parle c'est le principe actif est
le quinta normal en étoffant les jeunes
ont envie c'est que la compétition est
fait pour ça mais rapidement la prière
et sportives et et supplier par une
autre période qui est celle de
l'approfondissement et je pense que le
vrai boulot de lui bloquer accompli sa
mission il
il faut qu'ils perdurent le plus
longtemps possible parce qu'elle sa
mission est sur le tapis avec les
générations qui vont se succéder et
c'est un truc c'est un processus sans
feu alors souvent le judo ou le karaté
ou le taekwondo autres et on parlera du
dormi aussi juste après parce que vous
êtes aussi à un mètre du dernier
martiniquais le cru corps mais le judo
c'est souvent on discipline rigueur
physique force physique et mentale alors
bien bien bien utiliser un bien dire
usité il faut rappeler que évidemment
c'est un art martial c'est ça sert
d'abord à se défendre mais il ya aussi
une formation intérieur quoi et donc
quand on est sportif pratiquant du judo
de toute une vie par exemple dans votre
cas est-ce que c'est aussi synonyme
de joie d'épanouissement à tout âge ah
oui je pense que c'est la dimension prom
l'une des dimensions est plus fort plus
judo on ne peut pas être l'activité
aussi longtemps si on n'a pas le plaisir
et la passion de la joie à faire d'une
part il ya 3 6 mètres aux autres et à
participer aux avec les autres à 7 à
cette fête
enfin la réalité et c'est un processus
qui est très très très long je pense que
vis-à-vis des enfants vis-à-vis des
jeunes vous avez des adultes des
différentes populations qui y pratiquent
le judo c'est une
c'est l'élément essentiel qui nous
permet d'aller très loin que les et
permettent de goûter activités à trouver
la joie qu'il faut pour les encourager à
continuer jusqu'au bout et c'est eux
c'est un processus qui l'ont parce que
la formation du judo elle est longue à
prendre du temps ce n'est pas à 85 ans
il faut cinq ans silhouette ceinture
abdominale et quand on est paumé dans
chrome os a étudié du doubs vraiment et
ça va jusqu'au 5e dan de qu'il faut du
temps il faut de la patience et je crois
que c'est un petit récemment dans mon
point fort et je remercie beaucoup
francisco et mes professeurs que je vais
rencontrer qui m'ont donné c'était leur
façon d'abord ça tombe très bien parce
que vous suivez les pas de francisco y
compris dans le dernier parce que il
était lui-même professeur émérite de
judo c'était l'une de ses passions avec
bien évidemment la musique et la danse
la danse martial de chez nous le damier
et là dessus vous êtes fidèles
finalement à ce qui vous a enseigné
puisque vous êtes aussi un grand maître
du dernier le corps nola une des
caractéristiques de nos régions c'est
que autre sport et culture souvent ya
pas de différence à frontières msf à
lausanne
ça sent mauvais et c'est vrai que le
damier c'est du judo fait du point de
vue de la philosophie du point de vue
les caractéristiques du combat à mains
nues des arts martiaux
on repousse le damier tous les
ingrédients du judo du karaté l'aïkido
d'intervention a maintenue
l'asiatique est aussi africains puisque
l'on parle pas beaucoup mais ça vient de
là d'afrique tout cela est faux cisco a
eu l'opportunité et le pop et évite de
faire la liaison à l'époque et je
fouillais japon et victo japon se met du
damier a été l'élève de francisco
experts un judo champions judo est aussi
expert en damier moi-même tout
naturellement je pense que d'avoir su
bientôt leur grâce et janna magazine
martinique qui souvent avec autant de
possibilités je ne pouvait être que ça
et ça montre qu'on peut tout à fait
s'ouvrir au monde
évidemment être très inspiré par un art
martial dont les origines sont
lointaines se trouve en asie au japon
sans se couper de ses racines finalement
temps martiniquaise qu'africaine
rapidement 30 secondes parce que c'est
terminé ou à la racine de tous et avant
tout je pense qu'elle est elle est
africaine
[Musique]
la carrère gée parce qu'elle est
fondamentalement africaine compte tenu
que l'afrique est le berceau de
l'humanité
merci le cru corps d'avoir été dans son
caddie ce matin bonne journée à vous
tous merci beaucoup